it's pumpkin spice latte day
yes i know that many conservatives don't
like the pumpkin spice latte they don't
like starbucks very much i don't care i
love it it is a delicious drink it is
nostalgic it is is wonderful it's a
little too sweet you got to bring the
sugar down a little bit i look forward
to it every single year it's a sign of
the times the beginning of my favorite
season autumn it's wonderful okay but
i've got some bad news for the pumpkin
spice latte aficionados out there all of
the 17 year old white girls who listen
to this show the price of the psl has
increased dramatically according to a
report from cnn the psl will will go up
from five dollars and 45 cents that is
so outrageous five oh my that's what i'm
paying for this thing that is such a
that is a crime never mind five dollars
and 40 45 cents to 5.95 cents that's a 4
increase and i can't even blame
starbucks inflation is up year over year
at eight and a half percent starbucks
only raised to four percent not even
eight and a half percent i will never
forgive joe biden for this